hallo meine Lieben heute als ich Lotto
spielen war hatte ich die Idee den Tanja
makarit Adventskalender auszupacken boah
derit hallo meine Lieben hittet
irgendwie anders halli hallo meine
Lieben ich glaube wir müssen den
Elefanten im Raum ansprechen warum
bekommt Tanja makarit einen
Adventskalender und mich hat noch nie
jemand angeschrieben ob ich denn selber
mal einen rausbringen möchte es gibt ja
viele Firmen dieser Adventskalender ist
von food Vibes also nicht von Tanja
selbst gemacht sondern von food Vibes
tanja hat halt mit entschieden was
reinkommen und ich weiß nicht ob ich so
ein Angebot überhaupt annehmen würde
aber ich hätte gerne mal so ein Angebot
auf dem Tisch hören sie mir zu ich sehe
dieses Adventskalender Thema so ein
bisschen wie die Kunst ein Kunstkritiker
macht ja nicht wirklich selber Kunst der
kritisiert halt andere und so ist es
auch bei mir ich mach kein
Adventskalender ich kritisiere nur alle
die es
tun das ist gar kein food
Adventskalender warum bringt food Vibes
ein Adventskalender raus der kein food
Adventskalender ist dieser
Adventskalender kostet 74 90 finde ich
einen sehr guten Preis und wie wir es
nicht anders von Tanja erwartet haben
dieser Kalender hat einen wahren Wert
von über 300 €ing 24 von Tanjas liebsten
Produktpartnern wenn hier kein Snack
drin ist Beauty Food und Lifestyle
Bereich ich will die ganze Zeit was über
Tanja sagen aber mir fällt ganz ehrlich
nichts ein über Bibi konnte man sich
wenigstens noch lustig machen be Tanja
die ist halt da
ne optisch ist dieser Kalender ganz
hübsch so mit Goldschrift wurde hier die
Zahlen und wor drauf geschrieben und
Tanja makarit ich finde das Pastell
sieht auch sehr schön aus aber es ist
nicht weihnachtlich und ihr kennt mich
ich Brau es weihnachtlich
christm Nummer ein sind das Original
Tanja maerisch Zitate may the miracle of
Christmas F your heart with joy Türchen
Nummer ein da fängt es wieder an ich
kenne keine Marken eine Hyaluron
Augencreme Leute bevor ich hier noch
Taus mal Vibes oder Tanja makarit sage
dieses Video ist gesponsert von Hello
fresh und jetzt alle dieses Video ist
gesponsert von Hello fresh in der
Lebensphase in der ich mich gerade
befinde ist mein workload einfach extrem
hoch worüber ich mir aber keine Sorgen
machen muss ist mein Mittag und
Abendessen denn mit Hello fresh kommt
alles ganz easy zu mir nach Hause warum
rede ich wie eine stewardes der Ausgang
sich
dort einmal die Woche wähle ich aus
wechselnden Gerichten bis zu fünf
Gerichte für Timo und mich aus und das
wird dann alles ganz fresh zu mir nach
Hause geliefert damit spare ich einfach
so viel Zeit und das ist was ich zurzeit
brauche Zeit Flexibilität ist mir sehr
wichtig du kannst den Abo jederzeit
anpassen kündigen oder pausieren ganz
nach deinem Bedarf wenn du z.B wieder
mehr Zeit hast ich habe mich heute
entschieden für linsenauflauf mit Käse
kartoffelhaube die Lebensmittel kommen
portionsgenau bei mir an und die
beiliegende Rezeptkarte zeigt mir dann
die Zubereitung also wirklich mehr als
easy und was mich immer wieder aufs Neue
begeistert ist die inspo die einem die
Rezepte liefern auf manche Gerichte wäre
ich so nie gekommen und das bringt auch
noch mal ordentlich Abwechslung und
übrigens habe ich auch einen Rabattcode
für euch mit Hello Wanne können
Neukunden und Bestandskunden bis zu 120
€ sparen plus den Versand für die erste
Box gratis bekommen schaut einfach mal
nach unten klickt auf den Link und dann
könnt ihr mal schauen wie viel ihr mit
hellow Wanne sparen könnt für das was
ihr auswählt und jetzt geht's weiter mit
dem Video zurück zu hyaloron i cream
jecell again again wer ist das eine
probegröße 7,5 wenn meine mathematischen
Berechnungen mich nicht getäuscht haben
9 € ich werde viele Produkte heute in
die verlosungsbox packen und wenn ihr
euren eigenen malwannadentskalender
bekommen wollt dann folgt mir auf
Instagram denn diese ganzen Produkte
verpacke ich als neue Adventskalender
zusammen und dann mache ich ein
Gewinnspiel und vielleicht gewinnt ihr
einen mlwandekalender liebst immer dass
ich auf so eine chaotische Box einfach
zeig die kriegt ihr ich hab i cream
Nummer zwei für den Snack ich habe echt
ein bisschen Hunger kein Snack ich kenne
diese Marke nur durch Adventskalender
dieses Avon davon ist die Augencreme
auch so geisteskrank teuer ich habe das
noch nie irgendwo anders gesehen außerin
Adventskalendern schon wieder Hyaluron
da ist hyaloron Tanja schwört auf
Hyaluron Rose sugar Lip Scrub das finde
ich wieder cool ich denke mir halt
dieses Produkt so in der Handtasche zu
haben und dann immer so sein lipsrub so
dabei zu haben ist bestimmt auch cute
jetzt habe ich aber so viel Lippenstift
drauf dass ich das gar nicht ausprobi na
was für ein Glück dann bekommt ihr das
also bei Douglas kosten 10 ml 64 € das
ist diese Marke die so geisteskrank
teuer ist die ich noch nie gesehen habe
anderen Kalendern gab es immer diese
Augencreme die sie da reingemacht haben
Nummer
dre Berliner inghot warum ist das
Berliner so geschrieben das triggert
mich extrem ausg daacht in
Berlin cringe ausgedacht in Berlin das
ist ein Berliner ich kann keine Akzente
wir vertrauen auf die Gaben der Natur
kenf war auch drin ke Bammel ist
angenehm scharf das sind einfach
Produkte ohne die kann Tanja nicht
leben schmeckt wie ein Apfelsaft mit ein
bisschen Ingwergeschmack dahinter ist
angenehm scharf auf jeden Fall gesund da
freue ich mich bin gerade auf so einem
gesund essen Trip da wä jetzt nur
Süßigkeit ein bisschen schwierig okay
was kostest du
129 jetzt fühle ich mich
ready und in Türchen num vi wieder eine
Marke die ich nicht kenne m mask sollte
man das kennen Glory illuminating Blush
Drops Blush und Highlighter ich weiß
nicht ob es euch aufgefallen ist aber
ich wollte mich ein bisschen Titania
schminken ich weiß nicht ob ich es
geschafft habe was ich hier überhaupt
gemacht habe mir später aufgefallen dass
sie auf ihren Fotos mal blasch trägt
aber ich habe dann irgendwie kein blasch
gehabt und jetzt machen wir uns mal
blasch drauf ne da guckt schon was raus
das das sieht mir ein bisschen mehr nach
Highlighter aus als BL und Highlighter
blushwikung sehe ich jetzt nicht so ich
sehe die Highlighter
Wirkung aber ich muss sagen ich finde
den Highlighter extrem gut weil ich habe
nur ein Highlighter der sehr warm ist
und einer der sehr kalt ist aber so ein
mit so ein bisschen rosa
drin hab doch jetzt viel zu viel oder
ich habe so viel drauf gemacht ist auch
so flüssig ich bin bisschen bisschen
übertrieben ich habe jetzt kein
Highlighter sondern gefühlt ein ganzes
glänzendes Gesicht ja es okayes Produkt
man kriegt so ein schönen Glanz eh statt
so Glitzer ist das eher wie so ein
Schimmer den man dann so hat man kannst
nur auf der Website kaufen 15 ist 15
bietet das nicht an das heißt schon mal
nicht so schlimm dass ich das nicht
kenne 28 € ja hast du hier für Sachen
drin wir sind erst bei Nummer
5 je und len eine vanill
luftkerze ja riecht sehr gut auch eine
richtig krasse Größe sieht auch hübsch
aus mit sojawachs pflanzlichem
Sowi weitere natürlichen Inhaltsstoffen
6,99 Mensch wie viele Partner sie hat
die Tanja ncolaus und Tanja lebt in
Deutschland das heißt sie weiß dass
Nikolaus ist das heißt jetzt kommt was
krasses es gibt auf jeden Fall wieder
ein Zitat Santa Instagram
pictures
stunning ich verars euch nicht das steht
da wirklich Cent mein mein Instagram
sehen
würde t gönt an
P ein Armband
jaade das hat so richtig so
werbeegeschenk Vibes es ist ein pureli
Armband mit dem pureli Logo einfach ja
Armband komm aber ehrlich gesagt ich
würde es nicht tragen ich trage keine
Armbänder ist wahrscheinlich auch anders
bei anderen Leuten das kostet jetzt auch
sagen wir mal 30 € und dann ist gut
machen wir 15 Nummer 7 der Kalender
sieht jetzt so aus tanja hat jeden als
Partner und Gretel und Gretel ist eine
Berliner Make-up
make-upmke ey pencil in Gold was macht
man denn mit so ein eine ey pencil in
Gold ganz ehrlich der wirkt wie so ein
goldener
Buntstift uh ich habe mir das so auf die
Wasserlinie gemalt mit so voll so ein
Schimmer wie sieht das cool aus hoffe
man dfte sich das ins Auge malen 21 €
Nummer
8 wow es ist ein Waterproof Mascara mit
aranöl
kaltwasserresistent Willam ich dachte
hier kommen nur ein paar Gutscheine zum
Lotto spielen könntest jetzt in
Deutschland spielen und zwar über
Lottoland und ich hatte direkt Gänsehaut
vor Scham aber das sind ja echt wirklich
krasse sacheniams 10,40 € ich finde der
sieht total cool aus ich mache ih jetzt
aber auch nicht auf weil ihr wisst ich
habe hunderte Mascara und ich würde den
gerne einmal so drüber machen das lohnt
sich aber bei mir nicht ich habe so
viele der würde dann nur verschwendet
dafür kommt in die verlosungsbox kommen
wir zu Türchen Nummer 9 und Nummer 9 ist
immer das Beste Türchen weil Nummer 9
ist meine Lieblingszahl dieser Satz
hängt euch wahrscheinlich auch schon aus
den Ohren
oder der Emotion Cube badesprudel mit
konfettiseife riecht sehr schön so nach
Früchten Himbeere Erdbeere irgendwie
sowas aber Wiesbaden die Marke aus dem
Herzen Deutschlands wenn man das in
seine Badewanne macht dann kommt da so
Konfetti raus handmade with love was
sind denn das für Marken lief okay
manche Produkte sind wirklich weird kann
das einfach nicht so wirklich finden
made in
China ich hasse es dass Firmen so viel
Spielraum haben das wenn man sich nicht
wirklich ganz doll mit dem Produkt
beschäftigt das nicht checkt hier steht
F wunderbar wie es Baden die Marke aus
dem Herzen Deutschlands dann ist hier
vorne handmid und man hat das Gefühl oh
da ist so eine Wiesbadener Firma die
packt das so ein und verkauft dann diese
Herz badecbes cute made in China 2 € und
das noch als Türchen Nummer wie konntest
du nur Tanja Nummer 10 jawollo auf genau
SAS habe ich gerade Lust Haselnuss
Schoko dateln Kakaopulver glutenfreie
hafferflocken geröte Haselnüsse
Kakaobutter okay die süße kommt hier nur
aus den Datteln das sieht aus wie ein
kleiner
Keks lecker dadurch dass da Haselnuss
und Kakaopulver drin ist hat man so
nutellaweib also es ist schon richtig
lecker 1,50 € also das ist schon sehr
lecker diesen ganzen dattelschen denke
ich mir halt Datel sind lecker ist
einfach Dattel schmeckt nach
Karamel da wird eine tuchmaske
hydrogelmaske mit Ni oh das finde ich
sehr gut die werde ich behalten und
benutzen made in PRC
public public public Republic irgendwas
Republik China da sogar ein Peter Logo
drauf 3,95 €
Halbzeit ja gut das ist ein Tanja
Produkt diese goldenen Augen
da sehe ich Tanja mit morgens mit ihrem
Kaffee in dem Haus was Bibi gekauft hat
da liegt sie da und denkt sich so geil
ich habe es geschafft ich sehe mich
damit auch meinen Sonntag genießen
1€ 13 ja guck mal jetzt kommen so die
Marken die ich eigentlich mit Tanja eh
in Verbindung gebracht hätte Rosental
ist diese Marke die offen und ehrlich
mal so ein bisschen exposed hat dass sie
so wascharteine und so Jadesteine und
rosenqu von Alibaba von diesen günstigen
Seiten kaufen da Rosental drauf stempeln
und das dann halt mega teuer weiter
verkaufen so kenne ich diese Marke
bakuchiolsum das hat voll die guten
Bewertung bei Douglas eine super
Alternative zu Retinol meine Haut wurde
sowohl sichtbar reiner als auch glatter
leider habe ich viele retinolseren zuvor
nicht gut vertragen dieses Serum ist
aber wirklich super und ich nutze es
super gerne meine Haut ist so soft
geworden als wäre ich wieder 18 okay
diese Bewertungen sind Fake 17,50 € dann
gönnen wir uns doch lieber Dior oder
Nummer
14 Haferflocken in WT zuckersir
Margarine Trinkwasser pflanzliches Öl
vollständig gehärtetes Palmfett der
Riegel kommt aus Bratislava und das
Marketing macht Wien ich finde der sieht
einfach aus wie so ein richtig
ungesunder
Schokoriegel hier kann man sich richtig
gut tricksen so der ist ja gesund ist er
nicht
gesund der ist gesund der schmeckt als
ob man Porridge hart gemacht hat und in
einen Riegel gepresst hat aber sehr süß
das ist so ein Riegel wenn ich den beim
Wandern dabei habe dann kann ich alles
schaffen so Riegel braucht man schön so
zusammengepresste Kohlenhydrate Fett und
Zucker dass man halt noch mal richtig
Power bekommen 150 Nummer
15 dieser Kalender ist wirklich komisch
verwirrend diese Marke sieht doch auch
schon wieder aus als ob die also der
Riegel kommt aus Bratislava ist
Bratislava in Tschechien Slowakei hier
steht dann auch so ganz fett wieder made
in China drauf was ist das schon wieder
für eine Marke ich kenne sie nicht
gibt's bei Douglas Bella piier Lippen
Stift für 19 € das sieht doch so billig
aus nicht billig aber das sieht so ein
bisschen auch aus wie die wie das
Make-up was man so bei Lidl kaufen kann
nichts gegen Lidl Make-up aber das sieht
halt immer so aus wie ja das kauft man
eigentlich nicht bei Douglas das gibt's
hier was für eine Bewertung hattest hab
den Lippenstift zusammen mit Lipgloss
Liner und Puder gekauft fält nicht muss
das vor allem 19 € du bist bei Douglas
du hast die Qual der Wahl und du
entscheidest dich für bellaapier oder
ich stehe total auf dem schlaau und das
ist total bekannte Marke aber das glaube
ich nicht 16 komm dr Severin body
aftersave Baum for women für schöne
sanfte und glatte Haut nach dem rasieren
wachsen Epilieren auftragen und
einziehen lassen ich glaube darum
kümmern sich Frauen wirklich viel zu
wenig dass wenn man sich rasiert dass
man das auch wirklich danach gut pflegt
und die Haut behandelt wie eine frisch
rasierte Haut 5, 17 € dieser Kalender
kommt mir wirklich vor als ob wir den
seit 10 Jahren aufmachen was ist das
schon wieder hier für Marke das ist doch
schon wieder hier irgendwie Slowakei ein
hasenus kokosriegel mit 13% zuckerfreien
Füllung mit Karamellgeschmack und 25%
zuckerfreier Milchschokolade und
Süßungsmittel Vollmilchpulver mich
verarschen dieser ganze Kalender war bis
jetzt vegan überall steht auch noch
vegan drauf hier eine vegane Kerze alles
vegan vegan vegan tierversuchsfrei und
dann ist da Vollmilchpulver drin bin da
nicht so für wir sind nicht so low sugar
chocolate Candy ich bin jetzt einfach
nur persönlich angegriffen weil ich das
jetzt nicht essen kann ein geiler
Schokoriegel mit weniger Zucker voll
mich Pulver ma wir 150
18 lus naturkosmete mit Heilerde also
das wissen wir doch das ist die tanja
ist eine kleine Naturkosmetik Queen und
Heilerde schmiert sie sich super gerne
ins Gesicht eine zwei phasenpflege
irgendwiie Farben Heilerde und ich ich
habe im Hinterkopf dass Heilerde nicht
so gut sein soll ich weiß aber nicht
woher ich das habe wieso mein Hirn diese
Info besitzt jetzt hör auf daran zu
denken dieser Kalender ist ja auch
einfach da um um Tanja auch besser
kennenzulernen wirkt sie langweilig ja
aber nur weil wir sie noch nicht gut
kennen natural ja jetzt haben wir ein
hundertprozentigen bew lipbm also spar
dir doch die ganzen vegan Produkte mein
Gott ab hier hast du die Veganer eh
verloren das kommt natürlich in die
verlosungsbox Leute ich werde mir doch
jetzt hier nicht bien Wachs auf die
lippenschmieren 2,95 € 20 das sieht
straight wie aus der Apotheke aus
Getränkepulver mit 13% rubuschextrakt
aromatisiert mit Zimtgeschmack und mit
Süßungsmitteln zur Herstellung
zuckerfreier erfrisch Getränke ich liebe
reubusch ich liebe Zimt da freue ich
mich tatsächlich das auszuprobieren
Tanja wir sind uns ähnlicher als ich
dachte 4,50
im Royal Bunker trinken Sie Royal
Boss i want you naked tja wir kennen uns
doch noch gar nicht so lang aromatherapy
wenn das nach Yogastudio riecht Tanja
dann hast du mich wieder dann verzeig
dir das mit der vollmchokolade ich habe
so viel schlechtes über dich gesagt ich
Brau erstmal g Karma oh mein Gott es
riecht nach Yogastudio i love it die
feine Komposition aus ätherischen
Mandarin und lorbeöl wirkt
harmonisierend und stimmungsauffäend
diese Mischung aus Kopf und Herznote
hilft loszulassen macht
unternehmungslustig und also für mehr
positive Energie im Leben und ich muss
sagen Tanja du bist meine positive
Energie im Leben du kriegst so viel hate
ab so viele Leute reden über dich und
deine Beziehung du hast dich da einfach
in den Julian verliebt und was das für
ein Rattenschwanz mit sich zieht wie
viele schlechte Kommentare du schon
lesen musstest das ist wirklich scheiße
da hilft dir dieses Spray bestimmt mega
gut kann ich glauben es riecht
fantastisch möchte auch so ein
Aromatherapie Spray rausbringen 20 €
Leute ich ma sowas ich bring sowas
raus 22 nach diesem duftpray geht mir
wirklich viel besser Pixi oh ich GLB das
war auch so ein Highlight ich GLB inem
Kalender ein Rose Blush B ich wei weiß
nicht wofür sie ist ein Skin Booster die
boostet halt okay 15,45
ist gerade im Sale aber sie mein ja den
Verkauf den normalen Verkauf wir machen
30 das ist unfair vorletztes Türchen ja
Girl ich verstehe Dich ich hätte das
auch ins vorletzte reingemacht das ist
so boring das ist duschgill das musstest
du wahrscheinlich dann noch irgendwie
unterbringen es ist minty summerl ja im
Winter in meinem Adventskalender habe
ich gerne minty
summerline riecht das nach Sonne Strand
und Zärtlichkeit na gut das ist ja eine
Reisegröße und wenn man das zum Reisen
mitnimmt und du und Julian ihr verbringt
wahrscheinlich im Winter sehr viel Zeit
im warmen da ist ja dann Summer ist 50
Cent ich bin ehrlich 50
Cent es ist es ist Weihnachten und Tanja
hat noch ein Zitat für uns ich wünsche
dir ein wundervolles Weihnachtsfest Spaß
gutes Essen und eine großartige Zeit mit
den Menschen die dir wichtig sind frohe
Weihnachten deine tan das ist ein Tanja
Original und an Weihnachten schenkt sie
uns richtig da hat sie Bock und da gibt
es ja gut okay nee ist in Ordnung
braucht man an Weihnachten ein Liquid
Eyeliner von und Gretel und Gretel hat
richtig gegönnt ne und Gretel ist so
teuer 28 € unsere kleine Queen also
bevor wir über den finalen Preis
sprechen tolle Produkte teilweise drin
also hier hast du ein Eyeliner du hast
eine Kerze ein aromaspray Ing shot ein
Highlighter ein relativ neutraler
Lippenstift der 19 € Kost den man aber
nicht kennt aber gut ich meine
Lippenstift
Lippenpflege
lippenpeling Eyeliner irgendwas goldenes
was hoffentlich für die Augen ist
hoffentlich kriege ich keine Entzündung
Augen Patch eine Maske und ein bisschen
was Süßes ein nicht veganes Produkt ich
bin immer noch schockiert es ist ein
sehr ausgewogener Kalender jetzt rechnen
wir noch mal den Preis zusammen also ich
bin nicht auf einen Wert von über 300 €
gekommen aber
27588 das ist so nah dran das zähle ich
auf jeden Fall als Versprechen erfüllt
sind 200 € mehr als man bezahlt hat
diese Art von Kalender haben einfach ein
WINWIN win für alle für die Marke weil
sie ihre Produkte vorstellen können und
so das so ein bisschen als Marketing
benutzen für den influencer weil sie
Geld verdienen können und halt einen
coolen Adventskalender rausbringen wo
die Kunden halt auch wirklich noch was
sparen und da ja sind die Kunden auch
happy also alle sind am Ende happy und
ich finde die Auswahl der Produkte in
diesem Kalender wirklich sehr sehr cool
ich bin jetzt nicht ein Tanja makarit
ultra aber dieser Kalender beinhaltet so
alles irgendwie was man so gerne benutzt
mal zwischendurch und noch ein paar
Snacks man kann echt nichts falsch
machen ich habe hier sogar das Gefühl so
oh Christmas so ein Highlighter goldener
Stift Lippenstift ich hte niemals
gedacht dass ich das jemals sagen werde
aber ich empfehle den Tanja makarit
Kalender sie hat es ihren Hatern gezeigt
keiner da draußen hat an sie geglaubt
und dann hat sie gesagt jetzt erst recht
jetzt mache ich ein Adventskalender den
jeder wird und dann vergessen wir
vielleicht die ganze Geschichte mit Bibi
und sowas aber das werden wir nie tun
weil bibi und Julian bleiben für immer
bibi und Julian
bye